es uno de sus guardias que nos lleva
hasta el prisionero estamos en un
edificio de apartamentos la celda es un
pequeño local sin ventana la puerta está
blindada el recluso tiene tan solo 27
años usted es ruso sí estamos obligados
a mantener son anonimato y lo vamos a
hacer el prisionero no está maniatado
durante la entrevista un soldado
ucraniano está presente el soldado Fue
capturado en bacmut ese día su posición
fue bombardeada y perdido salta dentro
de una trinchera pensando que es rusa
una vez en la trinchera a 10 metros de
mí vi el color de Ucrania en los
uniformes de los soldados fue el momento
más aterrador una captura solamente tres
días después de su llegada a la línea de
frente
había 93 hombres en mi compañía en el
campo de batalla lo vi la mitad de ellos
murieron
este detenido fue reclutado en prisión
cumplía una pena de 10 años por tráfico
de drogas y complicidad de asesinato
cuando vio llegar al jefe de la milicia
Wagner
llegó en helicóptero saben la impresión
que eso hace a los prisioneros era el
único que llevaba pistola mientras que
los guardias los empleados de la prisión
solo llevaban porras para combatir en
Ucrania Wagner propone 100.000 rublos es
decir 1200 euros al mes
estaba harto de estar en prisión firme
por seis meses combato seis meses y me
beneficio de una reducción de pena y
ellos me dijeron si bajmud cae durante
su contrato van a sus casas directamente
21 días de entrenamiento y ya van al
frente el equipamiento es correcto dice
el soldado de Wagner pero falta comida
combatientes con experiencia y no hay
mando años durante el entrenamiento
intentaban convencernos todo el tiempo
Ellos nos decían que no éramos Carne de
cañón todo el mundo hablaba de esto pero
desde el primer combate lo pude ver
comprendí que nos teníamos a nosotros
mismos a ellos les daba igual que
volvamos o no que vivamos o no capturado
el soldado podría ser ahora
intercambiado por unos prisioneros
ucranianos
hay dos soluciones o me devuelven a la
cárcel o me matan por lo tanto no he
revelado ninguna información secreta no
tengo ninguna pero no creo que siga vivo
el detenido nos confía que es tratado de
manera correcta en los próximos días
Debería ser enviado a un campamento de
prisioneros en alguna parte de este país
en el que decidió com